foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
oh I think I was muted well hell God
damn
I can't even get my mic right oh my God
no we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to make sure we cut that manga is a
bunch of let me start over let me let me
on let me start over let me start over
Maga is a bunch of losers
they've lost several races just
yesterday one of them is Donna Deegan in
Jacksonville Florida beating a Ron
DeSantis mega-backed candidate uh she's
the only the second Democrat to win
that race in 30 years 30 Years also in
Colorado Springs Colorado
a Democrat wins the Mayoral race don't
worry don't worry I'll edit the audio
version and you won't even be able to
tell
everyone's commenting on how my mic was
muted
and if you are listening to the audio
version you're like I didn't hear you
muted that's because I edited it
yeah what the hell are you gonna do what
the hell you gonna do it's Monday no I'm
just kidding it's hump day it's
Wednesday
um it and today is my day to or
tomorrow's the day that I come on hung
over not today but anyways the point is
this
is Maga is losing Maga is a bunch of
[__] losers folks
I've told you this over and over and
over and over and over again and really
honestly you know I was thinking a lot
about this this morning because I'm
going to show you a clip and I know this
seems
um not on that subject but it totally is
of Elon Musk
absolutely justifying his belief and
opinion on why his anti-semitic remarks
towards George Soros is not anti-semitic
this is wild [__] we live in a wild time
we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life folks and the
big huge Maga Superstore is on fire on
the corner can you see it we're at the
intersection and the Maga Superstore is
burning to the [__] ground
a lot of people are concerned about
social media concerned about AI
um and I was talking to someone this
morning
I actually believe that
as much as a toxic Wasteland that social
media can be
um if if
there is uh
AI that is coming that will change the
world I actually believe in the long run
maybe not in the short term and the
short-term feeling
I actually believe that sunlight is the
best disinfectant and I actually believe
that what Elon Musk did to Twitter isn't
good for Twitter
it isn't good for the communities that
the Nazis on Twitter that he let back on
Twitter are targeting
but in the long run it exposes them
and exposes who they are Elon Musk
showed the entire world yesterday who he
was
and and I I you know I would love for
Twitter to survive
and I think Elon Musk thought that if he
got a new CEO then he could definitely
go out and say whatever the hell he
wanted whenever he wanted and that would
that would give him space it's not
advertisers big corporate money is not
going to flock back to Twitter because
of a new CEO when Elon Musk sits down
and says my anti-semitic remarks aren't
anti-semitic because I don't believe
they are listen folks listen to me
your [__] opinions your your [__]
opinions aren't truth okay they're not I
sit here every day all day two hours a
day five days a week
and I give you my opinions
and what I believe to be true
but that doesn't that doesn't
automatically make it that way
am I lying no
do I believe I'm telling truth of course
and I try to stay as close to the truth
in a 50 000 foot way what I mean by that
is I try not to get in the Weeds on
things
I don't want to debate certain details
and facts
and that's why I think we're having such
a struggle right now in this world is
because everyone wants to get in the
Weeds on every single point every single
data point every single fact
and that's just not the era that we're
living in
most people in this country don't give
two shits about most civics or our
government they don't
they don't it's the [__] truth
now I could back that up with all kinds
of facts and data and I'll show you this
I'll show you that and I'll show you
this and I'll show you that
but it's a feeling I have
I feel like I have the pulse of America
with you the audience
I've been talking to you now it's almost
400 episodes 397 episodes now holy
[__] [__]
and I believe that I'm pretty damn good
at this
whether you like me or not or you like
my opinions or not are you like my
commentary or not
but it's simply that
and we have to wrap our heads around
everything that we believe and any
opinion that we hold
no matter how Tethered to reality or
untethered from reality they are Elon
they're just opinions and they're just
beliefs
facts are facts
and I don't try to again I don't try to
make the audience sit through a ton of
data points and polls and
I think that's not the time in history I
don't think that is the way to
communicate
to to the Mass public in this country
of why our Civics why are politics
are important
does that make it wrong does that make
it less true no
does it make it more true because I
believe with my heart of hearts and my
conviction that Liberty Equity equality
democracy
are the way to achieve
those things
I mean I guess
but here's the thing
sunlight is the best disinfectant
and when America really wakes up to what
Republicans
Maca Republicans the real America First
Nazi party is doing to them
and realizes that the only reason why
they have ever voted for Republicans is
based on affiliation and availability
because in a lot of these rural states
there are no Democrats running
there are none
you go to the ballot and there's only
Republicans that's it
in a lot of house races and we're gonna
have Jess Piper on tomorrow
Jess Piper's gonna join us tomorrow
she's joined us before and she covers a
lot of stuff in Missouri and she really
goes after the Missouri uh legislators
there the the Maga legislators there
she tries to hold them accountable as
much as she possibly can but the other
thing she's searching for is candidates
that will run on the Democratic ticket
because in a lot of the Missouri house
races whoever wins the Republican
primary is the house seat that's they
get seated in the house just because
they win a primary
because there are no Democrats
but we see in places like Jacksonville
people are waking up
Rhonda santis is supposed to be the most
popular human being
if you want to call him that
if you want to call Ronnie that
I mean I I consider manga Android a lot
more accurate
baranda Santos won overwhelmingly
in the governor's election
he's been running around the country
pretending to run for president
they keep saying he's going to announce
between now and June I keep getting
these messages like Tony listen man
there his campaign and they're gonna
announce okay so [__] do it then
stop this [__] or get off the pot Ron
[__] or get off the pot that's what we
say here in Missouri
you're all [__] no wipe okay
I will believe it when I see it
I want him to get in I want him to but
he's supposed to be one of the most
popular politicians in Florida and he
can't
he can't make sure that the Republican
nominee
in Jacksonville for mayor the Republican
wins
against a Democrat awoke ass Democrat
folks
I'm telling you
and we I I told you in 2022 when places
like and and again you [__] out
there that love tyt
and love David packman I told you last
year they're full of [__] [__]
they're believing polls they're
believing [__] that isn't true
and you would and you think that I'm not
gonna go after them
there was no Red Wave there's a [__]
reason and it's not because more people
are part of the blood-sucking cabal and
Democrats are cheating it's because
maca's ideas [__] suck
if they have an idea
Jesus Christ I'm gonna show I'm gonna
show you a clip
of Rhonda santis this morning
this morning after he lost this race in
Jacksonville double down on pronouns
I'm not kidding you
he doesn't want school-aged children
learning Pro nouns
you're hearing it right
they're terrified of
pronouns what the [__] are you people
talking about
and they keep saying that that we are
ramming [__] down their throat shut the
[__] up the only people upset and
obsessed with pronouns in genitalia is
the Republican Party
there's no one else advocating no one
advocating to make pronouns anymore of a
of a an upper class word than any other
word
there's no [__] out there
yelling and screaming about their
genitalia or anyone else's genitalian
bathrooms besides my gut Republicans
and this is why Democrats are going to
win
do you think average Americans give a
[__] give a [__] if school age children
are learning pronouns
on sight word cards are you [__]
kidding me
you really you really truly believe that
the average Americans their number one
concern when they get up in the morning
is not their [__] bills it's not
their high ass Healthcare [__] cost
that how much daycare cost them how much
[__] food costs them
gasoline worried about that they have to
go to two [__] jobs today instead of
one both parents have to work two
[__] jobs to pay for the child care
and for the food
and you think their main concern is that
their sight word cards in in school
rooms
in their state that have pronouns on it
and we're standing around wondering why
the Democrat in Jacksonville and the
Democrat in Colorado Springs won [__]
off this is not complicated folks 2024
is a big year a big election the most
important election of our democracy's
lifetime I keep saying that I said it
about 2022 and I told you there would be
no Red Wave I said it over and over and
over again it's all [__] they're
bullshitting you they're lying to you
and I was right
and it's not because I have some sort of
[__] insight
or I have some psychic power
I just use my [__] brain and Common
Sense
just do the opposite of manga and you'll
kind of figure out what the [__] gonna
happen honestly it's kind of weird
yesterday we talked about the Rudy
Giuliani story and Maga a lot of manga
goes ass deep into defending Rudy
Giuliani that's not gonna go well for
them folks Rudy Giuliani is a pervert
and a drunk
and almost all the salacious [__] in
there has to do with drudy Giuliani
being a pervert and a drunk it's not
hard to believe that stuff whether it's
true or not it's not hard to believe it
it's not even that [__] surprising to
be honest with you not surprising at all
I mean you have the 2 million dollar
pardon scheme that's something that
seems illegal
as far as a federal charge but the
salacious stuff who the [__] does that
surprise
come on
they're gonna face plant on it just like
they're face planting in Florida at the
at the mayor level in Jacksonville
stepping on a huge rate because Ron
DeSantis is still out bitching about
pronouns the [__] grocery store
shells are empty in Florida the
construction sites are empty in Florida
because of your stupid war on wokism
whatever the [__] that means
and people are standing around going
what the [__] what the [__] are you
doing
in Missouri in Missouri these [__]
scumbag Republicans in Missouri voted to
make sure there's no red flag laws for
guns terrorists can get guns terrorists
they want terrorists in Missouri to be
able to go get a gun
I'm not [__] you
no red flags none nada anyone and
everyone could get a gun if if there's a
dude out there that's beat the [__] out
of his out of his significant other his
wife his girlfriend for for months and
months on end has numerous numerous
[__] restraining owners has had his
weapons taken away by law enforcement
because he's threatened to kill that
very woman with that gun he can go get a
gun tomorrow and Missouri Republicans
are [__] excited about it
and you think you think you think people
in this country are worried about
[__] pronouns like he and she they
and them get the [__] out of here Ronda
santis you are a dumb [__] you
think they're concerned about the
construction worker the color of the
construction worker's skin or where they
came from they just want their house
built and they want it built right you
stupid bastard
listen the manga the
the manga ideas
they're coming home to roost baby
and this stupid [__] culture war that
they are losing and really honestly they
already lost this culture War they
already lost this [__]
that's why they're so [__] desperate
to convince people that pronouns are bad
and we should be hyper focused on
people's genitalia
because they done lost the war
because people in this country don't
give a [__] about that
they don't care how someone else wants
to live their lives or that school
children are learning words
Kevin McCarthy this morning when asking
questions about the debt ceiling being
increased by the way I think I honestly
I I don't know if anyone at the White
House listen to this show you probably
should if you're not you should [__]
turn this [__] on but listen I'm telling
you what Joe Biden should do is what he
should do is call a a uh a press
conference not a press conference but a
national uh message he should cue in on
all the [__] Networks uh he should
take over the Airways for the networks
he should sign an executive order right
now right now [__] [__] two weeks from
now
um [__] the treasury
uh uh [__] House Republicans [__] the
negotiation what Joe Biden should do is
sign executive order that he's using the
14th Amendment to get rid
of the debt ceiling it's what he should
do [__] it just do it [__] him just cut
their legs out from underneath them
[__] them what what the [__] are they
gonna do take you to court good [__]
them go go let's go to court [__] let's
go to the Supreme Court because I don't
know if you're paying Digimon but this
morning Supreme Court apparently has
declined
to do anything about the assault weapons
ban in Illinois
hey you two ebros how how's how's that
Supreme Court that Trump got you going
huh how's it going how's it going for
you how's that going over there
that's right the Supreme Court is
declining
to put an injunction on the assault
weapons ban in Illinois
folks I I know it doesn't feel like it
right I know it feels like because the
media sells this [__] Trump is
themselves as [__] that the country is
50 50. it is not 50 50. that is a
[__] lie
that is a lie that is a [__] lie most
people in this country don't agree with
this nonsense
and they don't want the [__] and the
nonsense they really don't
and it's gonna show through in this 24
election I know it I know it will just
mark my words and we're gonna come into
next summer I'm gonna be [__] trying
to bash yes I will be bashing tyt and
David Pacman because they will be
believing [__] polls because they
want to be right
you understand that right they want to
be correct
they don't want to be authentic
they're not authentic you want
authenticity right here if you don't
think that this show is just me talking
you you have not been paying you didn't
watch yesterday's show
you did not watch yesterday's show
yesterday's show was a banger by the way
and if you missed yesterday's show you
need to go watch or listen to that [__]
you really should go watch it because me
Gabe in Texas Paul at one point I was
laughing so hard I was [__] grind
because it's probably the funniest
[__] episode that we've ever done out
of 397 now
I don't know maybe today will uh step up
its game
the point is this is that next year the
media and people in the media are going
to try to be right they're going to try
to be correct they want to they want to
call the shots and they want to say see
see see
I get to do that all the time all the
time I get to say I told you I told you
I I mean I've been telling you since the
end of January or into December
beginning of January that Donald Trump's
going to be the [__] candidate
and that Ron DeSantis probably wasn't
getting in the race and his clock is
[__] ticking it's been ticking I
believe the window's closed
Ron DeSantis is going to go down in
history as another Scott Walker that's
why he's flailing this morning and
talking about [__] pronouns again
Jesus [__] Christ run
good Lord just get in the race man I
want you in the race let's do this
let's do it buddy
but the Maga the Maga ideology is losing
folks and the reason why is because it's
maybe maybe 12 of the country Maybe
and yeah they're dragging along another
12 15 with affiliation because those
people are still voting for Republicans
even though it's gross and they feel
gross but folks I'm telling you I know
it doesn't feel that way but more and
more people are going it's enough enough
of the [__] enough of the nonsense
do your [__] job why do you think Joe
Biden is probably going to beat Donald
Trump by more than 12 million votes
that's right you heard it right here on
the Tony Michaels podcast May 17 2023.
Joe Biden is gonna beat Donald Trump in
the general election in 2024 by probably
10 to 12 million votes a margin it's
what it's going to be
100 and Joe Biden will probably have
less votes last time than he or this
time than he did last time and he'll
still beat him
it's gonna happen
and and there's only there's only a few
reasons that I have that I know this is
gonna happen number one is Democrats
know where every single [__] Biden
vote is they know where they are and
they they're Gathering up the
information to show where the new ones
are gonna be
not only that we're getting practice
we got practice in 2022 we're having
practice in some of these elections in
these states like Jacksonville Florida
I'm telling you I'm telling you I know
it feels like oh Joe Biden's old and
well he did a lot of stuff as president
but really can we sell that to the
American people who gives a [__]
who cares what we need to show them is
the ideas that Maga has again Kevin
McCarthy is standing up this morning I
forgot to uh finish this thought
and you know how it is my head is like a
pinball machine did you know that's how
I do this that's how I I manage to just
talk for two hours straight without any
[__] pausing is my my brain is like a
pinball machine
you know you know you know the old
pinball machines
that's that's how it's rolling around in
my head
and then I just opened my mouth and it
pours out
and for your enjoyment and your
entertainment
ah get you through the day as a
cathartic release on politics and the
[__] that's running rampant around
the country
like Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis and
Kevin McCarthy this morning Kevin
McCarthy when he was asked
is is there any chance at all that
they'll that they'll raise taxes on the
wealthy he didn't Flinch not a [__]
moment and you could you could hear the
plausible [__] just groan from the
[__] moglodytes behind him no nope
hell no we're not raising taxes on the
wealthy [__] that [__] and then he goes
into some stupid thing
which again he's not fully understanding
economics when he says this [__] he's
making this [__] up
but as if that's a great sell to average
Americans a why not to raise taxes on
wealthy people folks they're out of
touch they don't have ideas they don't
have policies they don't they're they're
only their only policy is to own the
libs that's it at all costs and it is
costing them a lot and we should
continue
we should continue to make them pay
I mean did
do you feel like anything they ever do
puts any kind of [__] in my armor
like any owning that they do with us
like this Elon thing he did this
interview we're gonna show part of it
and he's he's trying he's trying to say
what the anti-semitic remarks that he
had towards George Zoros was an
anti-semitic because because he believes
they aren't
the [__] out of here that we're not
stupid
I mean yeah we a lot of Americans may
not be paying attention we're not dumb
but the longer the short is it is that
most Americans don't even really know
who Elon Musk is folks they don't know I
know I know you think they do but they
don't know who he really is they don't
they don't know what these people are
actually doing to them Kevin McCarthy
and the Republicans they're doing a
top-line 22 reduction in their supposed
budget to raise the debt ceiling
and frankly the 22 Top Line is going to
affect their constituents the most it's
gonna hurt them the most because most
federal dollars
goes to Red States
in exchange
for money blue states are the ones who
pay more federal dollars than they
receive they have more of it red states
don't so a Top Line reduction at 22
percent is going to decimate rural areas
the very [__] constituents that vote
for these [__] morons to make sure
that the wealthy people in the blue
areas continue to get their tax cuts why
they sell abortion and trans people are
bad in the rural areas
and I know it doesn't feel like those
people in those areas will ever wake up
but I'm telling you little by little yes
it's gonna take a long time it's gonna
take decades to undo this madness but we
can't stop we can't stop yelling we
can't stop being loud we have to unmute
our microphones at the beginning of the
show by the way
we cannot we cannot relent
it is time to lean into our democracy it
is time to engage the 2024 election is
now on
and and we're being shown a pathway
forward the American people are showing
us with their votes in Jacksonville
in Colorado Springs I know it those it
doesn't seem like that may be a
reflection of America of folks the
reflection of America that we want in
those cities
is right before us
and and I'm telling you they're
flippable
they totally will will vote against
their affiliation but we are gonna have
to be loud as a [__]
We Can't Stop so what you should do is
come here every single weekday because
we're going to be loud and proud real
and wrong I don't give a [__] not two of
them not one of them not a single [__]
to give here on the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget to subscribe on
YouTube watch us every single day live
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific also
download every single episode in the
afternoon after we're done recording and
I cut it up and I put it on Apple
Spotify and Google because today I'm
gonna have to cut the front off because
there was this huge pause because I
didn't unmute my microphone see what
happened was as I most times I test my
mic
before I come on and I leave it unmuted
today I must have muted it and then I
after I tested it
my bad my bad excuses are like asses
Tony everyone's got them and they
[__] stink that's what I want you to
type in
um if you want to watch us on Facebook
that's another place you can watch us at
the Tony Michaels follow us on Facebook
if you have Facebook account I want to
thank everyone over on Twitch holy moly
the support over on Twitch
is crazy uh we are getting more and more
subscribers on Twitch and we're getting
more and more followers there's two
different styles over there on Twitch
you can be a follower and a subscriber
or you can be a follower here's the
thing it's free to follow us over on
Twitch please do that that would help
out a lot over on Twitch if you just
gave us a follow now
if you have an Amazon Prime account this
is very important if you have an Amazon
Prime account you can link your Prime
account to your Twitch account because
you get one free subscription with your
Amazon Prime account and the reason why
is because Amazon owns twitch that's why
with prime they give you one free
subscription on Twitch what it means is
is the show the Tony Michaels podcast
gets about five bucks but here's how it
breaks down twitch twitch takes half of
that twitch takes half that money
oh well and then they have fees so it
ends up being a couple dollars is what
it actually ends up being but it's a
great way for you to not cost you any
extra money and give the show monetary
support so go over to Twitch
link your Amazon Prime account and you
go to the Tony michaels.com the
directions are right there there's a
link I think it's the fourth one down it
says link Amazon to Twitch and you just
click that link it'll show you the
directions to link the two accounts and
give us your one free subscription on
Twitch every single month and that's
what you have to do you have to
re-subscribe every single every single
month so if you haven't went into your
Twitch account and resubscribed this
month do that today and thank you to
everyone who has been showing us great
support it's great honestly it's one of
the easiest way for us to monetize here
on the Tony Michael's podcast and the
reason why the reason why is because you
don't it doesn't cost you a thing if
you're an Amazon Prime user and it
doesn't cost us a thing to get it um so
it's really cool it's actually really
um a very very very very very very
impressive way for a show like this to
monetize so I appreciate all the support
over there and uh Shadow woman seven I
want to give her a shout out over there
because she's been gifting Subs as well
great Support over there on Twitch you
guys should go over and um talk to the
people in the twitch chat there's more
and more people showing up every single
day to watch on Twitch in the chat on
Twitch uh go go give the moderator Robin
over there some love too everyone stick
around
I got some video to show you we'll be
back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em [__]
em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show The Storm
Virgil over on YouTube
bringing up super chat I was talking
about how you can monetize a show like
this and I think what they're saying is
is that super Champs on YouTube
here's the thing YouTube doesn't like me
to monetize they don't want me to
monetize I've tried I've tried to get it
back we had it for like a month and they
took it away from me
um I I don't know I mean here's the
thing is that the show is free on
YouTube and I understand that YouTube's
a really big platform and maybe one of
these days they won't allow me to be on
it at all you know whatever apparently
they're loosening some are relaxing some
of their rules about the about the word
[__] which is good in my court
um but it only makes me assume that they
might be putting more uh strain on what
you can again I'd say which is fine it's
their platform right hey you know and
I'm on YouTube now we're here I've been
banned several times are suspended I
should say several times we are
suspended in March
um for seven days and for some [__] I
said I'm not sure exactly what it is
they don't ever really tell you exactly
what you said
or why they suspend you but the reason
why I don't have super chats is because
they don't they won't allow me to
monetize YouTube That's Right YouTube
won't so if you if you want to do super
chats you're on YouTube I mean I guess
you can go on [__] Twitter and Bug
them and tag them and you know you could
do that and just you know over over just
overwhelm them with tags and messages
YouTube and the YouTube team or whatever
it is
um you could do that uh I mean I don't
go over there and [__] and piss and
moan because they won't monetize me and
here's why is that if even if I get my
monetization back with YouTube Here's
the way I figured is I'm gonna say
something to piss them off and they're
just going to take it away again
so I I I get tired of fighting them
really honestly so if you want to do
like a super chat honestly like you just
want to give some money
um to the show which some people do
every week and some people every month
you can go to the tonymichaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com there is a
tit jar there it's basically the exact
same thing as a super chat you just
don't get credit in the chat for it
um is the only thing not everyone sees
that but there are people who do go to
the tip jar and leave us tips and we
appreciate all of it any monetary
support that you give that you can give
and I'm not saying that you should
because if you if you can't just come
and watch the show share it with someone
there's all sorts of free ways to enjoy
and support the show
um but if you want to give monetary
support because this is our job this is
what we do
um and I don't make the money I used to
because I want to do this at least right
now I know as the audience gets bigger
and we get more eyeballs and maybe we
attract sponsors to the show
um that it'll probably be a waterfall of
money I I completely understand that but
if you want to give like a super chat
like storm Virgil is is talking here
um the best way to do that is go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com there's a tip jar there and
you can you can certainly give a tip
there if you want to if you want to give
them a monetary support or if you want
to
um so there is that option and you
should be supporting creators
um that are
unapologetically pro-democracy right and
um and regardless of if it's monetary
support or if it's just watching the
show sharing it and getting um if you
see a clip sharing it on social media
um tagging them when you find something
I get a lot of people that tag me and
stuff sometimes that's how I find
stories and to be quite honest with you
you're the best audience in the world
yesterday proved it you were some of the
funniest son of a [__] on Earth and
you're some of the funniest son [__]
in the chat and we appreciate every
single last one of you whether you love
us or you love to hate us I don't care
um we want you here and we want you
talking as long as you're not being you
know [__] Nazi me and Nazi in the
goddamn chat we just might punch a Nazi
you know that kind of [__] happens right
Gabe Sanchez sometimes sometimes you
just gotta handle these Nazis in a
certain way I mean they're you just
Nazi be talking [__]
we will we will cut you off oh man so
these Democratic races I I'm I'm
actually um trying I thought I was gonna
get uh Dr Rachel bidikoffer on today and
I'm I'm I'm texting her but I don't
think she's gonna make it on today I'm
kind I'm kind of sad because I was
really when this morning when I woke up
in this news uh that the Jacksonville
Florida Mayoral race and the car I'm
like oh my God we gotta get better cover
on and talk about this I want her to run
laps on this one I would love to watch
uh doc just run laughs and just oh yeah
and [__] all over manga uh over these
races but what's your take on and have
you have you read much into these races
I read a little bit last night but I
mean just the fact that you know this is
uh you've got two people that
Republicans thought word you know didn't
have a chance right they they they they
they thought that there was going to be
uh you know Mega overload right and it's
gonna be a red wave right right
just like a slight little sprinkle but
it would be nice it would be nice if
they backed up their Waves by actual
like I don't know ideas that were worth
a [__] that would help yeah you know
ideas or just just anything that empathy
that might I mean that could go a long
way man that could go a long ways when
you're running an election I'm just well
it could go a long way in terms of being
a human too you know having empathy to
say hey I actually care for human life
hey I actually care about the well-being
of my constituents hey I actually care
that
um that our country isn't you know uh
have a a bunch of incompetent [__]
on one side who are willing to hold
hostage the debt ceiling right so
it I mean I think it's beginning to show
that like this this uh overconfidence
this Cockiness of like a red waves
coming and and just wait like the Reds
just gonna overtake all you know it's
it's really showing you that you know
people are beginning to think when they
go to cast their ballot right or mark
down who they want and I think it's
beginning to show right we thought or
you know people said
during the midterms that it was going to
be overwhelming 50 60 votes like crazy
[__] like that and it was like a handful
of votes right or a handful of seats
rather
um and so we're beginning to see
I think that Maga that Republican kind
of uh ideology is beginning to dry up in
certain areas because whether
constituents are tired of the you know
the lack of arrest that they promised
right or the lack of justice that they
wanted to be against these these uh
Republicans maybe they're finally seeing
that they're not actually going to
uh fulfill the promises or or
um or deliver on the promises that they
said right so you know whether it's the
people not having faith in the
Republican party anymore or whether it's
because they converted over the
Democratic party and they're they're you
know supporting a blue kind of uh wave
in that way
um I don't know yet but I I will say
that I think that this mag a republican
kind of ideology is drying up right
quicker than Ben Shapiro's uh
significant other yeah yeah yeah the
opposite of a cardi B video right
speaking of uh dry
un tasty things
um Ron DeSantis the the slogan let kids
be kids um
what
what why they're like oh
craps are so focused on children
indoctrinating children like you people
can't stop talking about this stuff so
here's around this I'm going to show you
two videos first one's gonna be around
DeSantis the second one is is gonna be
about the Jesus Christ
roads in Florida you can't make this
[__] up um what's going on with rose I'm
gonna show you a video man
they're getting woke down there dude
the roads are about to be unwoke because
Florida is where woke goes dying also
I'm going to show you some videos from
Florida where apparently um there's no
one on construction sites because Rhonda
Santos didn't get the memo that a lot of
migrants in Florida do construction jobs
not only that but you saw that there
were stuff that was coming out love the
weekend I want to say and Monday about
um all of the agriculture drivers
they're like now [__] this [__] man yeah
[__] you oh oh you're not gonna support
the workers who fill my truck get the
[__] out of here man right we're gonna
actually have a a truck protest you know
not just [__]
Convoy no trucker truckers are just
gonna be like we're not well because
there was a lot of well and and a lot of
people don't understand like uh because
Kevin McCarthy was talking about
um changing all the programs reducing
all the programs like Social Security
Medicaid Medicare oh wait the ones that
they said that they weren't gonna cut
right but but he said the reason why is
because we need to get people to work
and it's like wait but you don't want
people to work you don't want you know
the craziest part about some of these
videos that are coming out of Florida
like the the construction sites are
empty and all this stuff there's no like
huge white majority that's like rushing
and to take these jobs because remember
it was it was brown people replacing
white people it's the great replacement
you would think that these white people
be go claiming their jobs all of a
sudden well no they're not they're not
that's the thing right they're not like
I you know I I I've heard it for years
the economy works right well they say oh
man Mexicans are coming to steal your
job they're coming to take my job oh man
I can't let them come across the border
they're taking my job it's like okay
word
then let's see you go to that job let's
say you pick the heads of lettuce in a
field let's see you [__] pick
strawberries let's see you Chuck those
things into a truck let's see you work
in the factory that cleans those produce
and then packs them up into a truck and
then sends them off to whatever
distributor needs to go to let's say you
actually put in A Hard Day's work
because I guarantee you would not last a
[__] [__] in those conditions so
especially in ones where they're super
hot humid are not safe people are
passing out from exhaustion and you have
these companies
who are not paying a livable wage to
these people right and then you say oh
you know what we're now going to make it
illegal for anyone for anyone who knows
anything
uh about any of these migrants who might
be working in any of these companies if
you have knowledge you could now be
fined if you know these people you could
be fine if you're one of these people
you can be fined if I can be deported
all this stuff and it's like I really
kill the industry I have a friend who's
in the roofing business and he told me
one time he said I I actually pay double
the price for a Mexican crew over a
white crew and he said it's not because
it's a race thing he said honestly it's
because the [__] white Crews
think that that they have entitlement
and they don't have to work and they
don't have to work hard the entire day
like it's hard work roofing's a
[__] it's one of the toughest
[__] jobs out there you're on a hot
[__] roof all [__] day you're in
the you're melting in the Sun and you're
doing hard labor carrying shingles up
the roof sometimes on a very steep
incline and he said I absolutely will
not he said I used to hire white Crews
but I won't even do it anymore because
they can't finish a roof because they're
bitching and moaning and complaining
about I mean here's you go a good
example of roof I was I was out for a
walk with my dogs earlier today and
around the corner they're uh two Mexican
guys only ones on the job and they were
replacing the actual like [__] you
know Spanish style shingles which are
right also not light right especially
stacking up I'll try to try to try to
carry a stack of clay shingles yeah
because like the idea it's like oh you
know if you had a flat roof where it's
like oh I'm just gonna nail this in easy
gun gun you know boom done but those
shingles man [__] one slips well the
whole thing I mean you've seen videos of
like shingles going down the roof and
you're like well everything's broken and
now I have to pay out of pocket to cover
the expense of those ones that were
supposed to be firing up on this roof so
not only that but you have to take the
shingles off right then you have to go
up clean it
prepare it and then bring the new
shingles up and set those up and finish
them right it's like a you know it's a
probably a job that they'll I mean they
were doing a couple garages down the
street but I would have to say that
they'll probably finish by the end of
the day right
um if not then they'll they'll be
finished by tomorrow but it's not easy
work and it's job that it's it's it's
jobs that no person who ever complained
that oh they're stealing our jobs would
ever do or whatever be successful in
right but they they're they're too
entitled to do a job that is that hard
to labor um yeah Raven says um here is
talking about hispanic work ethic and uh
Hispanics do have a really good work
ethic and the one one of the reasons why
is because they want to be in this
country they want to be here folks it's
it's it's their drive to work ethic
because the American dream is come here
work hard and make something of yourself
right that's what everyone's always been
told you you can be anything you want to
be in America as long as you'll work
hard and they they believe it they
believe that if you come here and you
work hard like actually work hard not
like talk about it and talk and [__]
and moan about someone taking your jobs
and then you won't go do the job when
like a Governor Mike Ron DeSantis won't
allow migrants heads up but what a lot
of people don't understand is in our
history of our country and this is why
immigration is so important and this is
why migrant workers are so important not
just Hispanic migrant workers but
migrant workers in general is because
migrant workers come here
because they want to work hard to be a
part of this country that's why migrant
work ethic is so high is because they
don't have the privilege of not working
hard to Make It in America they have to
work their [__] asses off to make it
somewhere they're they're 200 years
behind guys like me okay that's the
[__] truth that's the truth and so
when you when you when you see this uh
what Rhonda Santos is doing by go vote
go broke no no Ron when you focus on
woke
you go broke like right your weight
you're focused on woke you're gonna go
broke and it's killing the state here
here's here's an example of it this
morning this let kids be kids this
morning and here's what he's talking
about he's talking about sight word
cards that have pronouns on them now he
spins it a little different game but
he's talking about sight word cards
that have the word sight word you don't
know what a sight word is you obviously
do not have children in school so when
children in school learning how to read
they have what they're like spelling
words they were called spelling words
When We Were Young okay but but sight
words because you don't actually learn
how to spell like they say yeah they
used to say you learn as well yeah yeah
you you it's a site it's by sight right
because you can actually read a word
that is misspelled yeah right because
you you you're citing it right you're
not actually sounding it out but anyways
they're sight words so it's like he she
the now would could should
um words like that words that are you
know basic reading oh okay so they're so
they're like on flash cards yeah oh oh
okay [__] flash cards but but the
thing is is like when we were kids we
had a spelling list the spell you know
he had a yeah like every week we come in
and be like you have a spelling list of
these guys
but you know they over time they realize
that that's a really dumb way to teach
kids how to read right is there any
anything on the back side of the card or
is it just the word itself it's just a
word what's his word what's this I mean
I'm sure it's the same word because I've
seen different ones right there's like
you could make your own sight words yeah
sometimes it's a sight word list like
you know the schools will send home a
sight word list they don't call it a
spelling list anymore because they
really don't even focus on spelling
because more than anything they want you
to memorize what the word is just by
sight by sight oh okay all right so
that's why they're I don't know man this
education sounds pretty well for me
listen yeah
and I'll just I'll just memorize it
right right I I I get it I get it but
here listen to Ron DeSantis here talk
about how dangerous
pronouns are is [__] idiot at Florida
students and teachers will never be
forced to declare pronouns in school or
be forced to use pronouns not based on
biological sex
we never did this through all of human
history why does he have his hands can
you just go back to the beginning really
quick like I just wanna I mean we can
finish it if you want but just the way
that he's like because he's got his
hands up on the podium and he thinks
that's awkward he's like is this what a
human would do like he's thinking he's
thinking yeah I put my hands
oh there they are
there it is like he just like he's like
getting air inside the the sleeves if
it's where a human would put its hands
Computing even okay so I don't have to
finish this because everyone knows where
this is going is go woke get broke or
whatever right right we don't want our
kids learning pronouns and he's saying
that people have to declare pronouns
which I would love anyone anyone so send
me any proof everyone calls someone then
I don't I uh Android
does Santa
Ronald doesn't
oh my God man this is weird stuff
um the right so that's so [__] dumb
here's here's the reason here's the
reason why no you don't say you don't
say let's say you're like oh I'm gonna
clean this school of all its corrupt
pronouns that's what I'm gonna call now
corrupt pronouns okay that's what it is
they're clearing the school up on this
corrupt pronoun [__] and so at the
end of the day when somebody's like hey
you can't use he she they whatever in
inside this school right and they're
like oh well okay my child doesn't learn
how to address people or things anymore
right so if I call you English [__]
English right like I I don't need I I
see I see a man like Ron DeSantis uh
because he's not a he's not a man and
he's not a human right but if I were
surprised he'd try someone in Florida
and I saw someone like Ron DeSantis and
I addressed Ron DeSantis as
she is running
to be the next president of the United
States how upset would Rhonda santis and
all of his supporters be you know what
that's a good idea we should just miss
miss James I'm gonna misgender
everything start misgendering them just
to show them how ridiculous it is just
to show them how ridiculous it is her
campaign
I mean her campaign though is not
official yet but that's true seems to be
really giving it her all it is and
trying her best to pretend to pretend
that she's a human to to be human but
also pretend to be running for president
and if anything like she'll be the first
female president which is pretty amazing
it is kind of cool that right I don't
know I don't know if she has it in her
right like I don't know if she can do it
I don't know if she has the
she's really weird I mean she's really
weird she is a bit odd for sure Ronda
santis Rhonda DeSantis Rhonda Santos
whatever we want to call her right you
know whatever her name is but at the end
of the day like I think it's important
that we acknowledge who she is right
she's trying to be the president of the
United States which again is a big
accomplishment for a woman
I just you know I I I just want to say
like we should call what we're seeing
here this is history in the making right
it's crazy it's crazy to think that a
woman would be running against Trump
within the same within their own party
right
it it is it is weird that two women are
running in this primary I mean they
don't wear makeup they won't wear heels
they're you know they do their hair
weird they wear they wear as costume
every day it's really kind of weird
um so let me show you what the pronoun
cops in Florida are doing uh because the
pronoun cops in Florida have this bill
it's it's 1191. it's it's [__] real
this is a real thing this is a real
Builder trying to pass in Florida
um well I just let the video tell it
here let's see what 1191 is
as if as if things in Florida
couldn't get worse
sir House Bill 1191
they're gonna pass a law here we go to
allow roads in Florida to be paved with
radioactive material what with
radioactive waste because they have too
much radioactive waste in Florida so
they're gonna
pave the roads
with it
[Laughter]
so the roads are gonna be Radioactive
with nuclear waste
what
okay
[Music]
I'm telling you listen when you put the
pronoun police in charge of government
this is the type of [__] they come up
with in Missouri I don't know if you've
noticed this
in Missouri Missouri Republicans the
real first American Nazis here in
Missouri they passed a law where there's
no red flags they literally they
literally and they went on the floor and
they were bragging about this they were
like yeah no red flags like you know you
used to be the party of terrorists not
getting guns like what where in the
where the [__] have your
I mean I thought you had two brain cells
but Jesus Christ you wasted those away
good War I don't know I mean like you
have to have to yeah I mean that's I
mean if that's the case love why can't I
bring a bomb on a plane well exactly
wait why shouldn't you really honestly
it's your god-given right I mean it's an
American well-regulated militia hello
hello and you should be able to pack a
bomb around for crying out loud why
can't you conceal and carry a [__]
bomb also the fact that people even want
to ask why I have a bomb if I have
that's right dude that's an invasion of
privacy right get the [__] it's an
infringement of your right and really
honestly anyone questions you carrying
around a bomb on a plane or on a bus or
on a train in a car in a house with a
goat on a boat it doesn't matter Sam I
Am where you carry this bomb if you're
questioning it you're infringing on the
rights and it's treason really honestly
yes but here's the thing
in Missouri with these red flags because
there's not a ton of terrorists running
around I mean
domestic terrorists there's plenty of
them there's plenty of domestic
terrorists running around here's the
thing though is that in the state of
Missouri it's one of the highest
gun violent States per capita and the
reason why is because it's stupid
[__] in charge here yeah
because they absolutely have uh the
money from the gun lobby stuffed in
their [__] Pockets here's the thing
here's the crazy part is that whose
lives are actually at risk here is
mostly women because what happens in a
lot of these cases is a man who is a
[__] nut job uh has access guns he is
violent towards a woman rather his wife
girlfriend significant other whatever
the case is
um women will fire restraining order
after straining or after restraining
order a lot of times the police will
come and take that person's weapons but
in the state of Missouri the Republicans
want to make sure that that [__]
has no impedement no check no nothing no
red flag on them at all when they go
purchase a firearm to kill someone and
most the time it is a domestic dispute
most time gun violence in this country
isn't mass shootings and that's one
thing we fail to talk about is that
people aren't we're not even protecting
people from their [__] lunatic loved
ones because we're not willing to admit
that yeah
you should red flag be honestly I think
anyone who comes in this country I don't
care where you came from I don't give a
[__] why you came here
you should have a red flag on you if you
arrive in this country to buy a [__]
firearm I believe if you go to a
different state if I am in one state and
I drive to another state I should be red
flagged I should not be able to buy that
firearm no absolutely not that should
not be a thing I should not be able to
drive from one state to another state
with a driver's license and buy a gun we
shouldn't be able to do that [__] now
this morning Gabe Sanchez and I'm going
to come back to Florida here in a minute
yeah yeah but this morning the Supreme
Court
um actually
told
um the the people who want to stop and
put an injunction on the assault weapons
ban in Illinois uh your home state
um actually the Supreme Court said no
we're not going to get involved in that
um Illinois assault weapon ban is is
good to stand as of now they're not
going to they're not going to interfere
in Illinois passing laws that's at least
good but the problem the problem is is
that places like Texas and Missouri and
Illinois you can just like we were
talking about firecrackers you just
crossed the border and you can get all
the guns and all the firecrackers you
want yeah really honestly
um and it's because there's just no
regulation of it in in Indiana Missouri
um Iowa I mean Republicans love to talk
about how Chicago has such high gun
violence and no and we have the most
risk like uh you know uh strict laws
when it comes to guns and it's like yeah
well okay but you're not stopping anyone
from going to another state to purchase
it and then coming back in the state
right like you're you're
you're regulating the state of Illinois
but you also have to now focus on what
happens with other states and so yeah to
the point of like firecrackers and
fireworks I yeah I remember you know
going over in Gary Indiana
over to Indiana and be like great let's
buy the [__] firecrackers and bring
them back over back in right
it that's what happens with guns it's
not complicated to understand that's why
I say
um we should just red flag if you go
from one state to the other
um we shouldn't have gun shows those
should be absolutely off the table you
shouldn't be able to buy a [__]
weapon out of a trunk of a car if you
buy it from an individual you absolutely
if you buy a gun from an individual and
you don't go through a certain process
that's not a legal purchase yeah I mean
I don't know why we have to do the same
thing with ours right exactly we have to
stop acting like we have to stop acting
like that it's only the people that is
the problem it's only the mental illness
that is the problem do we have do we
have mentally ill people in this country
absolutely every single one of us have
some sort yeah yeah a mental illness
dumb [__] we're all we're
Americans I mean we're we're forced to
[__] work our entire lives we never
get retirement we have to worry about
the [__] Republican party stripping
us of all all the [__] that we want all
the [__] that we want to do with our
money and that's not even including in
all of the different stint like us as
humans were not built to uh to
experience this much stimuli especially
stimuli that is traumatizing whether
it's surviving uh you know attack
attacks domestically in this country uh
mass shootings which obviously are on
the rise you know the the the experience
of having loved ones or yourself being
involved with war going overseas
deploying what have you right there are
all these different things that you look
at that and say we were not built to do
this we were not built to experience and
and handle it's and so when someone's
like oh
we should focus on mental health and
make sure that people get the right
therapy or or treatments or able to
[__] digest and not have to car
compartmentalize in in and reprogram
your brain to
uh cover up any trauma that you
experience and God forbid something like
triggers it one day and you [__] snap
right because you didn't get the proper
treatment
but you have all these situations like
again humans we were not built for this
we were not we like we grew up kids it's
like you know one of our one of the
first memories I have as a kid in grade
school was [__] 9 11 and having to
worry that my friends families and that
lived in the Sears Tower at the time
were going to potentially be the next
Target right like some of the earliest
memories are of these different attacks
Wars what have you right our parents
their parents like when this is human
history though right right and just
because we did it historically it
doesn't mean that we should keep doing
it right well but here's the thing is
that we're not gonna We're not gonna run
away from uh our mental illness we're
humans like you said and storm Virgil
brings up a great Point here and says
wait are you telling me not everyone is
perfect no and I'm not saying every
single person has mental illness I'm
just saying every single person has some
sort of mental illness at some point in
their life right their brain is sick at
some point your brain is sick also maybe
even if sadness all reasons why your
brain is sick and and that's that's the
other thing too is like
the Republican party and people on the
right always want to uh villainize the
idea of oh you cried or you were upset
or you did this it's like your body's
reacting to some sort of [__] trigger
that's happening and just just the idea
of you seeking treatment to be like hey
you know what I think it'd be good to go
talk to someone every week or every
couple weeks or whatever nothing wrong
with that nothing wrong with that you
could be the happiest person totally
fine you you know you don't have these
these emotional reactions let's say or
whatever like just talking to someone is
totally fine it doesn't make you weak it
actually makes you [__] strong the
same way that you know we talk about
liberalism is a strong strong strong
thing to have the idea that you say hey
you know what we should have different
points of view we should have a diverse
group of people we choose we should be
open-minded and think about things
differently and say hey you know what
just because I don't want it I mean
someone else doesn't right or like maybe
how we did it before wasn't the best way
and now we want to fix that going
forward so you know whatever way you
look at it but obviously Republicans and
that party Maga is a mental illness like
Angie Bailey saying yeah here on
Facebook he says Maggie is a mental
illness now I I have to disagree a
little bit I think manga is created by
their mental illness right sure okay
fine I mean you could I mean maybe just
a different kind of perspective on it is
I I think the same way that uh some
people's mental illness because again
I'm not saying all people are mentally
ill but I am saying all people at some
point in their life their brain is sick
but here's the things I also believe
like everything else in life is a
spectrum right right exactly and there's
like there's like oh my God this person
has is schizophrenic that's what it
might be that's like way on the other
end maybe maybe you lose a loved one and
you're just you're really sad for a
while and you can't figure it out when
you have depression that's a sickness
your brain is sick your brain is sick
and it's okay for your brain to be sick
it doesn't matter it doesn't mean that
you'll never get over it doesn't matter
it doesn't mean that you won't be able
to to heal that sickness now now
Republicans don't want you to heal that
sickness they don't want to do anything
about it they don't want to give you any
kind of [__] mental health care at
all right
um but this is the manga way this is the
manga way is to is to say here's a
problem and we're actually going to
create a solution that makes it way
worse so let's go back to Florida I want
to point this up yeah and I'm going to
jump back but here is here's a prime
example
of Rhonda Santos and the manga
Republicans finding a problem and then
having a solution that makes the problem
worse watch this video from a
construction site
hello everyone this is an update today
is Tuesday May the 16th it's not Sunday
there is my truck with grass
and this is a construction site here in
Davenport Florida 20 miles from Orlando
and this is all you see it's 9am
usually at this time there's a lot of
people here working all kind of
contractors doing their job
roofers of course a lot of noise and a
lot of Mexican music
this is what you hear today
quiet
so it is happening
it is not fake
it's not a joke
it's one contract there
um so it goes on and he's he's
explaining it but let me give you a
little I've I've worked in construction
um and I I've actually Done Construction
myself and I've worked for construction
companies doing the Contracting and I'll
tell you that the reason why
um construction workers get up really
early in the morning and they go is
early to job sites number one is because
they need daylight as a general rule
right otherwise it's expensive to to
[__] have lights on
um when there's no daylight so so the
sun uh gives them their work light but
also in Florida it's it's like this time
of year it can get [__] hot in the
afternoon and heat generally doesn't
equate with hard labor right it doesn't
doesn't compute very well so what
they're trying to do is get up as early
as possible when the sun's up for it to
be as cool as possible until they can't
work any longer because of the Heat and
then they go drink some Bud Light
probably
um because you know maybe not in Florida
but and here in the Midwest they'll
drink Bud Light or or Michelob but they
go drink some beers and they they be
with their families and they eat food to
re-energize it re-energize to get up in
the morning
um and it's a culture right and
construction work as a culture and it
doesn't matter if you're if you're
Mexican if you're if you're white
um it is a culture it is a culture it's
something that these people whether
you're a plumber or an electrician or
roofer it is a world that they live in
it is a different world than most
workers if you're an office worker or
something of that sort it is a culture
it's just different
um and it's crazy to see that on a
Tuesday Morning this guy's dropping off
sod that's what he's dropping off yeah
he's got he's on his forklift and you
can see he's on his forklift here and he
pointed out that hey there's my truck
back there and I'm dropping them at 9
30. at 9 30 right he's dropping off
loads of sod and he's driving off loads
of sod to put in these yards that are
practically just you know made of sand
here
um and because it's it's Florida but I'm
sure they're going to have some sort of
sodded part of the yard for it to look
green to sell these brand new houses but
I'm sure these people who are building
these houses are contractors right and
they're building these uh this isn't a
homeowner building these houses now it
may be that a homeowner has bought these
houses and the contractors building them
for them right but a contractor is
building these houses and their crews
are gone and the reason why their crews
are gone is because Rhonda Sanchez like
I hate brown people and we don't want
brown people to work they're stealing
job they're not stealing they're doing
the jobs they're doing the jobs and the
other thing too is like this has uh an
impact on on this on the children of
those families because now because now
easy easy on letting kids be kids I'm
just saying you say let kids be kids but
at the same time the parents
who are afraid that they'll be deported
or the you know will lose their job or
whatever it might be they're not taking
their kids to school anymore
because they're afraid of this
they're so afraid that they will be uh
the recipient of this [__] up new bill
that they're that they're afraid that
their children also might be impacted
whether you know what you know what
happens too when that happens
when the school doesn't have the
attendance because the school doesn't
give a [__] or undocumented maybe they
lose funding uh that that is that closes
down that you don't have to get sent to
another District that might be many many
miles away which might make it more
difficult for those families who don't
have the means to send their children to
another weird so you're saying like
there's a domino effect right and
Republicans don't think about the long
lasting effects that it has but they
they got on the libs [__] you
gotta own the libs that's key that's key
and tenement to their policy what
happens to all the white kids that Ben
came over there
huh well yeah well that's that's the
other thing hey hey that's just the
price you pay for Freedom so when you
have guns in schools when you have guns
in schools and no books that's just the
price of Freedom game Sanchez that's
just I mean you go woke the school goes
broke right
the children don't get an education they
also stay broke because they don't have
the requirements to even get a fast food
job well you know what you should do
that in that case is what you should do
is buy Josh Holly's new book and he will
teach you how to be a man and that will
solve everything listen to this crazy I
don't mean to skip and it was kind of oh
it's funny I I want to show this clip
watch this of Joshy here telling us how
to be how to be men
the LIE is that by being a man you make
the world the worst place
oh my God okay honestly by by being a
republican man you definitely do right I
mean for sure now this next this next
phrase is [__] just oh projection
like like oh man Josh you couldn't do it
any better let's listen why is that we
don't need strong responsible men in the
world and that all masculinity is toxic
that oh my God no all listen listen to
me when I say this this doesn't mean you
want to say this all toxic masculinity
is toxic yeah if it's toxic masculinity
it is like look not not all men are
trash but Tony and I will acknowledge
the fact that men are trash yeah right
okay
a lot of time [__] a lot of things up
and there's a lot of things that it's
like dudes yeah it'd just be better if
you let someone who didn't have as much
testosterone as you
right like let the women do this [__]
they're smarter they're even they're
cool they're you know even they know how
to get [__] done yeah they know how if
you're gonna talk
yeah go ahead go ahead I'm gonna give
you I was just gonna say like if you're
gonna talk about someone who's able to
handle all of the [__] [__] coming at
you in life women and minorities are the
two groups that I would say that are
are the the people that can that can
most the best handle this situation okay
in terms of like just multitasking
[__] throwing everything up in the
air and still being able to juggle it I
would say those are the two groups
minorities and women right well I've got
you a great example here oh my God this
is [__] fire watch this [__] this is
yes this is yesterday uh in a house
hearing where um the the Republicans are
talking about DC crime crime we need to
fix crime let's listen to representative
Crockett here my Republican colleagues
want to talk about keeping DC streets
Crime Free
has just been indicted on 13 counts 13
felony counts right but have they
exhibited any courage to say you know
what we will disallow this in our body
we will make sure that we expel this
individual they have not so what I don't
want to hear is that they care about
crime because if they did they would
start by cleaning up our own house and
mind our own business instead of coming
after DC so thank you so much for your
time thank you
she's like look I got 24 seconds on the
clock so let me just run through this
[__] and [__] roast you you guys want
to talk about crime you want to talk
about crime let's talk about the people
that are corrupt in politics I mean when
she when I first heard her say that line
she's like you want to talk about let's
talk about the halls of Congress let's
do this I thought she was honestly going
to bring up Jan six and be like [__]
[__] are running running
running a mess in here and smearing [__]
on the walls right tasing their balls
crazy I honestly thought that's what she
was gonna bring up and then she was like
my fellow freshman congressman
indicted on 13 felony counts I was like
oh damn dude God damn but yeah it was I
was like that's what I said
damn okay so some people in the chat
were saying earlier that um there may
because uh um I forget the
um the representative that brought it
Garcia brought it to privilege yesterday
yeah so today they're gonna vote so
basically yeah actually are they going
to vote on the privilege right so
because that's what a lot of people
they're not voting to expel George
Santos no voting to bring the expulsion
to the floor yeah but there's also a lot
of people don't understand I think I
think that's what's gonna happen they're
good there's a vote so basically what I
read Earl and I'll pull the article
right here so basically George Santa's
newest problem is the house to vote on
expulsion measure uh after months of
ridicule blah blah blah a week ago today
they said okay uh Democratic
representative Robert Garcia introduced
a resolution Tuesday to expel indicted
Republican representative George Sanchez
from Congress the resolution is
privileged I mean a
republican-controlled house must bring
it to the must bring it in the next two
days so there's also this development
that happened this morning uh which it
sounds like the House GOP is going to
refer George Santos expulsion resolution
to the ethics panel uh there was a
meeting this morning that happened
between
um the some some top New York Republican
uh lawmakers as well as Elise stefanik
and uh Kevin McCarthy
and they met to talk about how to
properly do this they're like uh well
you know typically how it's done is
someone is charged with the crime and
then we do that or we have to go this
other way but we have to very careful of
how we do it so it sounds like
Republicans are
at least in the background right now are
moving
to allow for this to happen but they're
trying to be very careful that it
doesn't [__] up their chances in terms
of how they have the votes and so it
sounds like a house majority whip Tom
emmer a republican from Minnesota has
sent out a notice Wednesday telling
lawmakers that they should vote on a
motion to refer the resolution to the
ethics panel around 5 PM
um it we also have to remember that
Kevin McCarthy said last week after the
indictment happened the 13 felony
charges happened that he said he was not
going to support him for reelection he
said right focus on right and he was
going to leave it up to the Ethics
Committee I think yeah yeah which I I
think is is obviously a cop-out to be
like I'm not going to support him but
I'm still going to use him when they
need the votes well here's the thing
here's what I want everyone to
understand is Hakeem Jeffries and the
Democrats what they're doing here
um is they're giving and I know this is
politicizing it I know this is what
Republicans are going to be like oh see
Tony's saying it too yeah this is
exactly what's happening a king Jeffries
and the Democrats in the house are
trying to gain one more vote on their
side
um for this uh uh debt ceiling and
they're trying to threaten Kevin
McCarthy's ability to do this uh by by
having absolutely ridiculous negotiating
points holding America hostage holding
our economy hostage holding people on
Social Security Medicare and any kind of
social program hostage
um Democrats and Joe Biden shouldn't put
up with it honestly I think Joe Biden
should actually just again do a national
message and sign an executive order 14th
in the debt ceiling tell them to go [__]
themselves hey guess what your debt
ceiling doesn't exist because I just
14th it dumbass I just I signed the
executive order that I'm using the 14th
Amendment to kill the debt ceiling take
it to court do that and it'll kill the
debt ceiling altogether the debt ceiling
is unconstitutional it's a fight we
don't have to have it's really stupid
leverage that Republicans use they get
blamed when it [__] up and when it when
it [__] them every time they still use
it because what they're trying to do is
protect wealthy people's tax cuts and
trying to take social benefits away from
poor and the people who need them but
here's Garcia apparently in the press
conference this morning talking about
um this a privileged motion uh to expel
George Santos let's listen and George
while standing accused of unemployment
fraud
it's a time to restore this body to what
it should be a beacon of democracy
freedom and Truth
remember we all filed this group The
Resolution three months ago even before
those last group of charges
now with power comes great
responsibility and the representative
from New York has clearly no interest in
the public good okay so I know the
volume's low on them the audience is
pointing that but there's nothing I can
do about the the volume that I get from
the video can you find the uh I can't
find where he was on the house floor
um bringing this uh motion of privilege
because a lot of people
um again
this is sometimes a breakdown in our
Civics is that they're not actually
going to vote to expel George Santos
that's uh they may they may eventually
but that's not what their their voting
to bring essentially bring the expulsion
to the floor
um and they're using the motion of
privilege to force it uh and Hakeem
Jeffries and Garcia here are the ones
that are using that uh motion of
privilege
um to bring it to the floor and what
they're trying to do is force Kevin
McCarthy to get rid of George Santos is
what they're setting a trap folks for
Kevin McCarthy is what they're doing
um and and what they're doing is forcing
Kevin McCarthy to actually uh do this
here's the um here's a clip of Garcia
giving the motion on the floor uh in the
house uh this was this was yesterday
right so
um he uses he um he uses article one
section five Clause two in the
Constitution
um to bring this resolution uh here
here's a clip Mr Speaker
pursuant to Clause 2a1 of rule nine
a ride to give notice of my intent
to raise the question of the Privileges
of the house
the former resolution is as follows
half resolution
114. resolve the pursuant to article one
section five Clause 2 of The
Constitution of the United States
Representatives be and hereby is
expelled from the House of
Representatives thank you Mr Speaker
resolution off from the floor by the
member only other than the majority
leader or a minority leader as a
question of privilege of the house as
the media president only at a time
designated by the chair within two
legislative days after the resolution is
properly noticed decision
the form of the resolution noticed by
the gentleman from California will
appear in the record at this point the
chair will not at this point determine
whether resolution constitutes a
question of privilege that determination
will be made at the time designated by
the consideration of the resolution
okay so it's very complicated the rules
are very complicated what what is what
is very obvious here in this clip people
are saying that there's choppy sound the
is broken
can people hear us right now or is it
choppy again
and then probably not that I'd made that
sound
choppy sound I think it's your audio
it's you it's you is it me or is it Tony
[Laughter]
like a better drive through yes yeah
see ya
okay so here's the complicated thing
um
am I am I choppy is it choppy and how
about now how about now how about now
how about now how about now
uh if you could say um yeah it's it's
both it's both and I can't tell Tony no
Tony's fine yeah it's it yeah it it's
sometimes um I don't know what it is
about uh Gabe coming into the broadcast
but sometimes the connection doesn't
happen through the software and it makes
us both choppy
um but here's the thing it's complicated
about
um setting motions and everything on the
on the floor they said it went away when
I when you went out it's it's you it's
the problem
I don't know if you're choppy or hold on
hold on you may have to switch your mic
better
better because it says better better
good I I yeah better okay all right
sounds good okay so so here's the thing
is um the the thing that this clip shows
mostly
Chompies down through that good good
okay I think I think we're gay I think
when somebody says that I'm uh gooder
said that Sanchez guy he's nothing but
trouble it's true good trouble
so so the thing that's most obvious in
this clip and I don't know if you caught
it here uh let me see if I can uh back
it up here a bit and show you a
screenshot of it uh you see the guy in
the background behind Garcia you see
this guy right here oh yeah he's yeah
he's been a real uh real Troublemaker
these days that's speaking of good
trouble that's Daniel Goldman he's a
former prosecutor he's also a former
counsel uh on the first impeachment he
was one of the ones that was actually
doing a lineup of questioning uh in the
first impeachment and if you remember
for for congress he was he's also the
one that got Margaret Taylor green to
get [__] censored in that yeah
Committee hearing get her the [__] he's
like uh actually literally here's the
rules that's the only time that's the
only time whenever I've heard someone
pull up that actually what happened and
then it's like oh it was used for good
right because actually and it's like
okay
man right but here's the thing is that
the Democrats and Daniel Goldman is a
good example of that is that they know
what the [__] they're doing they're
serious folks they're serious about
policy they're serious about their jobs
they're not just trying to get [__]
Fox News clips
they're actually trying to do their job
and Daniel Goldman is it's I would say
the the clips that are made
they don't go here
Democratic Representatives uh lawmakers
Senators they do not start their day
thinking what's going to get my
15-minute interview or my 15 second clip
that's played on some right wing uh uh
media show right Democrats go in and say
okay let me hear what dumb asinine thing
you're going to try to do today and I
will correct you it just so happens that
Republicans set up
the joke oh and we're choppy again no go
switch your mic go switch your mic oh
man go switch your mic
go switch your mic you need to switch
his mic I don't know why it's something
um the mic the mic that he has is kind
of like mine it's a it's a Elgato Wave 3
and it runs off of software so if
something's funny about the software
then he's choppy
um so he needs to hook up his Yeti which
doesn't require software it's just a
hard line so okay so I want to show a
glitch while it keeps switching his
microphone here is yesterday and Gabe
actually um retweeted this I think um
that's how I found it is uh uh this is
Daniel Goldman and he's dunking a
witness in the trash
um because this witness does not realize
that Daniel Goldman not only is a
congressperson and a serious lawmaker
he's also a former prosecutor and he's
he's a constitutional scholar and he's
worked as general counsel for the
Congress and four committees so he knows
a thing or two about rules in Congress
like he knows a couple things about it
but watch this is hilarious watch this
murdered in mass shootings every single
year almost two per day mass shootings
sorry 600 mass shootings far more people
and we're supposed to be talking here
about vandalism
give me a break
you can't even say you can't sit here
mrerson you were an employee of the
Department of Homeland Security and I
want to get to that in a minute you
can't even acknowledge what your own
agency said that the biggest domestic
Terror threat is white nationalism white
supremacy you're trying to get us a
Gaslight us up here as if antifa which
Mr Rosas apparently the expert now in
organized
terrorist activity has overruled the FBI
director
who says there's a headline says antifa
is an ideology not an organization no no
no let's not listen to the FBI director
let's listen to sorry what's your your
title senior writer at Town Hall who is
going to tell us that the FBI director
is wrong and I'd like to introduce
there's no question uh I'd like to you
can't say games so he's talking to that
he's talking and he's using his time
which a member of Congress in these
committees have the absolute right to
use your time however they want it's
their microphone it's their time they
can either question the witnesses or
they can just Yammer on and on and on
and on and on and on and make a point
Daniel Goldman is trying to make points
here he questions himself of what the
what the witnesses
someone said get rid of that woke ass
Mike
okay
it's the same woke Mike I use what is it
your computer that is not that is not
updating the software or what it could
also just could be something else all
right all right you're gonna make the
audience horny and then we're gonna get
on all kinds of horny talk like we were
yesterday
oh my God
I want everyone to appreciate or or
understand our appreciation of
everything you guys have to offer as our
audience we love you we care about you
we love the fact that you show up every
day two hours a day
or listen here here come here to listen
to us talk about this dumb dumb dumb
[__] that we say every day like me
Whispering into this mic all right I do
want to say what I do want to say about
Goldman look Stefan says they want me to
say I love you
I love you
anyway oh my God yeah what uh what I do
what I do want to say is there's a part
of me that knew that new
like it just seemed too [__] fluid
for him to be like oh what's your what's
your title oh right you're the you're
the [__] you're the [__] right
you're like nobody there was a part of
me that he knew like right what his
title was because he's like he was
trying to show right he was trying to
show that this guy's an idiot that this
guy is not an expert witness no exactly
but the idea that he's switching around
the papers I was like this is this feels
too fluid the way that he's able to come
up with this I was like he knew what the
name was because he knew how dumb it was
and he knew that this guy wasn't serious
so when he's messing around with the
right he's like oh yeah what oh yeah
you're the [__] writer at the town
hall right like you're no one of
importance that has any sort of
expertise or background so much so that
I don't even know your title at this
point right yeah he's like he's like
yeah
now here's here's here's the thing is
that the guy tries to ask he thinks
Daniel Goldman is not asking a
rhetorical question here right and he
tries to answer and Dana goes like hey I
didn't ask you a [__] question and
and that the reason why Daniel Goldman
says that is because he knows the rules
okay now I know this seems a little
petty yeah but when when you are in
Congress and this is one reason why
Kevin McCarthy is probably going to lose
this battle on the debt ceiling and it's
likely going to be lost um when Joe
Biden 14 sit and that's That's All She
Wrote and they will never be able to
bring this argument again because that's
one thing Republicans don't want with
this debt ceiling thing is that the the
ability for them to hold the country
hostage based on the debt ceiling they
don't want to not be able to do that and
they're gonna do it if if they don't
[__] get their [__] in order here and
just pass a clean bill let the president
sign it and move on about your [__]
way and have the stupid [__] battle
where you don't want wealthy people that
to pay taxes and you want to take away
benefits from poor people in your
constituents right go do that battle
somewhere else don't do it by destroying
the economy because in magaland they do
want the economy destroyed because they
believe if they destroy the economy Joe
Biden will lose but the problem is is
that the country is going to blame it on
them not on Biden they're they're
boneheads oh God damn it is it choppy
again they're saying it's choppy again
you were [__] up today I'm so sorry I
just want to apologize for everything
I've done wrong to you today and just
know that I'll be better yes
they're saying you're a job right but
it's because you watch watch now tell me
tell me if it's choppy with just me on
tell me if it's chappie
it's someone says it's Tony
come on come on now Tony I think it's
time
today sometimes
Tony is fine without Gabe's connection
[Laughter]
listen the good thing is is I control
like I control him it's like I can just
bring him in and out in and out
in and out
okay so I I have no I have no idea
I don't know if if um if you're gonna be
able to stay on if you can't then it it
is I am choppy when he's on I don't know
what it is about his connection
um but it is it is Gabe Sanchez it's not
does that mean what am I chop liver
yes yes you are choppy liver I guess is
that that's the thing
um yes it's gonna be the recording too
the recording's choppy we went over this
I'll just say this if it's a there's
like 20 minutes left I'm gonna I'm just
gonna leave early okay because my
[__] it's my computer and I don't
know what it's gonna do so I just want
to say I apologize I apologize I
apologize
you all like that
like that and it feels like that some
some people are saying sounds good now
it's gonna happen it's it's it's
something it's something about his
connection on his end
Teresa says she's not going to watch
anymore because I was being immature I
just want to apologize to Teresa it's
all a joke
I'm sorry
Oak what are you gonna do it's live it's
live and we can't we can't change it
when it's live like we can't go back and
yeah there's nothing I can do about it I
mean once it happens
yeah yeah if we knew it was happening
right but you know okay I again I'm here
just making a [__] joke I'm trying to
make light of a situation they can't
[__] hear me I think they're joking
that they're no I know I know well I
don't know I mean I'm not sure maybe
Teresa's joking maybe she's not maybe no
idea I think Teresa is just joking she
would never she would never Escape
because it's just you listen when I'm on
by myself and I don't have guest or Gabe
on the audience could be gone now I just
want to apologize I'm sorry I didn't
mean to push her out
oh boy yep it's happening again it's
it's as you're on more it just chops up
and then it makes me choppy
um so
[Music]
and your connection
I muted it
right
I don't I don't know if it had I don't
know if it works when you mute it I have
no idea it may it may it may not be
choppy we mute it may be because
um you're on your Yeti right
yeah it may be because you have an open
mic and something about the bandwidth on
an open mic maybe I don't know your
camera's fine today at least you're not
like at least you're not lagging right
laughs
I mean at least you're not lagging okay
so let me play the rest of this Goldman
clip let's play this Goldman clip
introduce uh by unanimous consent an AP
article saying the FBI director says
antifa is an ideology not an
organization without objection sword
no you're not I didn't ask a question
it's uh it's a gentleman's time he can
spend it anyway Jesus
oh boy excellent can I can I can I
debate you and Daniel Goldman's like no
[__] you this is my time [__] this is
not a debate I'm the congressman I have
the seat I'm the one that gets to
question you for my constituents and
when I ask you a question you will
answer it and if I don't ask questions
you sit there and you shut the [__] up
it's hilarious and the best part about
that clip is that Daniel Goldman
understands the rules let me show you
someone who doesn't this is [__] wild
[__] is it Marjorie Taylor green of
course it is oh God the real the real
Petty Eddie not this goddamn Petty right
right exactly exactly here is here's
Marjorie Taylor green and this is a
prime example of manga not listening to
words that people say like literally
this this witness is telling her
something about the year 2022 and
Marjorie Taylor green absolutely does
not hear anything she says and the
reason why is because Marjorie Taylor
green does not like what she says listen
to this when it comes to politically
motivated violence in 2022 every single
murder was committed by a right-wing
extremist okay so this witness is saying
in 2022 which was last year
all the politically motivated killings
okay follow me on this if the killing
was politically motivated not domestic
not some kind of Heat of the Moment
murder but politically motivated all of
them every one of them in 2022 was from
a right-wing extremist are you following
so far now listen to what Marjorie
Taylor green picks out of this it's
[__] mind-blowing listen to this
every single murder in America was
committed by a right-wing every single
oh my God you stupid [__] [__] there
no no they're very selective they're
very picky about what they like right
right and when you say you know
extremist right-wing extremist political
you know like they they're like ah I
can't compute all these words
and Margaret Taylor green and remember
this is the same party that wants to you
know defund schools they want to remove
resources funding uh Teachers Pay banned
books education different classes these
are the people that want to strip
education away and these are the people
that are clearly the ones who should be
the recipients of better education right
wing extremists like Margaret Taylor
green and again it goes back to the idea
that if there are Nazis doing something
on T online on tv whatever it might be
and you see people calling out those
Nazis you should not be the people
defending the Nazis especially if
someone says hey you're defending those
Nazis you're a Nazi and I go no no I'm
not a Nazi well then stop [__]
defending the Nazis stop trying to come
up with some excuse as they're like oh
oh the these guys are undercover feds
it's FBI and in this case she's like oh
all murders all you're saying all
murders well but but Gabe this is a
prime example of they don't [__]
listen yeah they only hear what the [__]
they want to hear and the only reason
why they do this is so that their
political bias is correct again I'm
gonna show this clip from Elon Musk here
in just a little bit to prove this point
because that's where I'm going with this
is that not only do do [__] Democrats
understand the rules in Congress but
they actually listen to one someone says
something and the reason why Marjorie
Tater green isn't listening is because
she's not serious yeah she's not serious
about these things she doesn't give a
[__] once right little clip of her
saying you said that all murders were
because of right-wing extreme right
which is not at all what she said now it
gets Dumber it gets Dumber I know it I
know I say it a lot like hey it's dumb
but it's gonna get dumber and they do it
every time so listen to martij the green
make what is the stupidest thing she's
ever said well one of it's hard to tell
really at this point but make it even
dumber listen politically motivated
murder was committed by a right-wing
extremist are you sure about that I am
what are you are you aware that the uh
Tennessee shooter just recently
identified as a man and she was a
biological woman okay so she's talking
about the shooting in Nashville okay now
if anyone if anyone would remember back
I don't know like five minutes ago when
I was playing this clip and what the
witness said was in 2022 which was last
year yeah but numbers meganomics last
year
politically politically motivated
murders see if they would just if if you
would just remember back then you would
know that the Nashville shooting that
Marjorie Taylor Green's about to talk
about did not happen
last year it happened
this year and it wasn't politically
motivated there was no political
motivations to that murder that we know
of that the motivation that we've seen
is that there was some sort of [__]
crazy [__] going on with someone giving
therapy to somebody and it was a whole
there's there's things that happen there
that are not politically motivated it's
not politics and this woman is speaking
to political gun violence is what there
is what this witness is speaking to in
2022 again let's watch her just [__]
dunk this idiot in the trash was she a
right-wing extremist as well don't let
anytime is expired allow the witness to
answer the question so that was a
shooting that happened in 2023
there is no evidence
ideology motivated that shooting exactly
when it comes to politically motivated
violence in 2020 again it's just it's
just Insanity that not only does
Marjorie Taylor green not hear what this
the words
and maybe it is maybe it is a problem
with Maga where they're like look we
don't want pronouns we don't we don't
want to we don't want years in our
language anymore we don't want to do
that we don't numbers are hard Tony all
right can you wait I know I I know that
I know that you you know you dropped out
of college but can you tell twice twice
twice can you tell me nice [__]
don't get it right can you tell me is
2023 uh greater or less than
2022 well
as a two-time College Dropout I'm fairly
confident that 2023 is probably more
than likely a larger number okay okay
okay so so then would you say then based
on that response that 2023
is the same as 2022. it is probably more
than likely different than that oh yeah
they're two different numbers imagine
that's all the proof I need
uh big Stefan says Tony always says
twice about dropping out of college
because it's the truth yeah well I mean
what do you want me to run why would I
run from the truth and the truth is I
dropped out twice and just just
2023 is not the same as 2022. me
dropping actually it's not the same as
me dropping out twice especially when
you know it's it's like God damn it she
it it's like one of those moments in
school when the teacher's like okay
repeat after me you know and it's like I
blah blah blah whatever just like simple
like five word phrase right and like
okay repeat it back to what I said
it's it's almost like she's playing a
game in telephone and it's just between
two people right it's not even it didn't
even go to [__] 10 people to come
back to her and be like so what I heard
was that all murders that's what she
said she literally like she's like look
in 2022 which is a year you know the
year of right like the idea the idea
January 1st maybe maybe that's what the
witness should is just like look fiscal
year like from January 1st 2022 to
December 31st of 2022 all the
politically motivated murders so any
murder that had any motivation behind it
that was political right was
the murderer was a right wing like you
extremist that maybe she would have been
like oh yeah but but as soon as she says
these things she's like oh all murders
are committed by right-wing history are
you sure of that like yeah I'm pretty
sure what I just said but what she
somehow amazingly uh this idiot
missed in the statement which was that
in 2022 right all political murders
right or political murders were you know
uh or motivated blah blah correct
Marjorie Taylor green hears that he says
2022 out political out all murders all
murders were from right-wing extremists
and it's like no you okay there were
like certain conditions that set up a
statements and you decided to say nope
nope like you're like motive nope you're
nope like no context right but all
murders were political are you sure and
that's when she says are you sure of
that like Liz I I know all murders
weren't committed by right that's
ridiculous
seconds ago well the problem is here's
the problem is that
um there was a a [__] psychopath that
went into
um a representative Connolly's office uh
the other day in New Mexico with a
baseball bat apparently swung and hit a
few staffs a metal baseball right uh
whatever it was like the two people in
Aid and an intern I think it was the
intern's first day in the job well my
only thought was when I saw this news is
Jesus it's great I'm I'm honestly I'm
glad they had a baseball bat
um and I know that sounds crazy
Republicans but but we're in that time
we're in that time like 15 20 years ago
like Jesus Christ are you kidding me God
damn why would someone but your first
instinct is God thank God they had a
[__] baseball bat not a goddamn
automatic weapon right because there
would be so much more Carnage right it's
[__] crazy that that's my my instinct
I I was talking to a teacher the other
day a my a friend of mine and um and
speaking to this Instinct and then we'll
move on to Full Circle here to the idea
that uh manga is going to lose lose
because of their dumb ideas where they
believe their opinions are and their
beliefs are are [__] truth
um it's the reason why they're losing
but a friend of mine and was talking
about now
um they were at school
and there was balloons that they had for
some sort of Celebration and some of the
students were popping the balloons and
it was like pop pop pop pop pop pop pop
pop
yeah and a student in the classroom was
like raised up and was like hey is that
is that gunfire and he said for a moment
it kind of entered his brain but he knew
it was balloons right yeah yeah but he's
he was telling me this I said man that's
crazy that balloons popping in a school
right which is like a normal
as an adult but terrorizes terrorizes
people in a whole another part of the
school
and it started a conversation about what
we would do if it really was real and
this sort of thing and I was just like
Jesus Christ that's and and Republicans
don't see that that you're terrorizing
people and that and that is the point
here with Marjorie Taylor green is she
is trying to run cover
for [__] domestic terrorists who are
committing political murder because of
ideology one reason why is because
Republicans want anyone and everyone to
have a [__] gun right and again think
[__] think
everything that that [__] psychopath
in Conley's Office was carrying a
baseball bat I mean I feel really bad
for the staffers who were on the
receiving end of the baseball bat but
let me tell you something I I am so glad
that that he was armed with just a
baseball bat and not
um I mean it is unfortunate that we live
in a time where we have to be thankful
for that I'm thankful for that weapon
versus this other one right right now
it's it's crazy and I guess it sparked
this debate in Congress about having
Capital police but God damn we
[__] Kevin McCarthy won't even raise
the the unconstitutional debt ceiling so
we can pay the debt that him and Donald
Trump racked up in the four years they
were [__] in Congress and we're we're
gonna think that we're gonna give
protection to every single member of
Congress and their staff in their field
offices and their congressionals off and
get [__] that no we're not we they can't
even they Kevin McCarthy can't even
stand and say the rich should be [__]
pay more taxes and the poor shouldn't
have their benefits taken away because
we're scumbags they won't even stand and
say that so they act like he's going to
give protection to anyone but himself
[__] off come on give me [__] and
and yes and DK Hall some people were
pissed off that I said the word [__]
McCarthy is a [__] he's a [__] [__]
too frankly all the republicans in
Congress are [__] they're just [__]
[__] and people get offended if I say
the word [__] the reason why I'm saying
is we have a lot of listeners in
Australia and they love the word [__]
and they know what the word [__] means
okay they know what the word [__] means
the word [__] I mean it has a lot of
different meanings mainly the word the
word [__] especially in Australia means
you dumb bastard like that would be the
direct current also I mean I mean it it
can be for other things too right you
know right you know but yes Marjorie
Taylor green is a [__] Kevin McCarthy is
a [__] uh Paul gozar is a [__] Andy
Biggs is a [__] Steve scalise is a
[__] [__] Lauren bobert is a [__]
[__] and I could go on and on and on
with all these [__]
speak in a major [__] oh look at this
[__] [__]
God if you're offended by the word [__]
or any words really honestly if you're
offended by any words any of them uh any
of them you probably should not well I
mean here's the thing are you more
offended by the word con are you more
offended by a pronoun well that is true
maybe maybe this is his pronoun uh major
[__] is um
is he wants pronounced okay so if anyone
is not aware Elon Musk
thought that it would be a good idea to
go on an anti-semitic Trope about George
Soros spreading lies and misinformation
and really stupid [__] the reason why
comparing him to Magneto right well
that's kind of I'm [__] weird but
here's the thing
um I don't know if you know the um the
history of Magneto and that character
but the and but I mean you literally
just have to watch I think it's the
first opening scene in the first X-Men
movie from 2000 2001 right and
understand the origin of Magneto and
understand that you comparing into
Magneto is
kind of and it is there's even another
there I mean they bring it up a few
times but there's then there's a later
film I forget which one yeah I think
it's um the new class or something like
that yeah yeah first class I think it's
that one where you know it goes into his
history
right anyway or Argentina right I think
yeah because you know he's going to kill
Nazis right exactly that [__]
murdered his family yeah because Magneto
is Jewish
yeah that's the story that's the the
backstory of Magneto but Elon ear he
went on um and I think it was under Ed
O'Brien krakistan's uh thread I'm not
sure I I can't remember
um he was responding in replies and he
was saying anti-semitic tropes
um and I believe that this is why Elon
actually is faking that someone's new at
the CEO because he wants to say this
[__] but he knows it's going to be
unattractive to
um advertisers corporations he's like oh
I'm not the CEO anymore but you're still
running product engineering you're still
Tweeting yeah stop stop tweeting still
the face of the company there's a CEO
sure but she's kind of just like uh a
figurehead but you're still the voice
that is controlling a lot of the
functioning and and daily activities of
the company itself and not just Twitter
Tesla [__] uh uh you know SpaceX like
you're the idea he's like I'm gonna say
what I can say and I'm gonna speak the
truth all this [__] it's like well
here's here's here's his justification
and this is why Elon Musk is Maga this
is why he is Maga and and it's and he's
why he has the white supremacy attitude
um I mean is it surprising the guy grew
up in South Africa right he's a
part-time baby yeah of course and here's
the thing is that when you listen to
what he says okay he's he's speaking to
a fascist ideal it's not a liberal idea
it's a fascist idea listen to what he
says and I'll I'll break it down for you
listen to this interview it's weird it's
hard to follow because Elon is a [__]
idiot but listen but how do you make a
choice you don't see I mean in terms of
when you're going to engage I mean for
example even today Elon you you tweeted
this thing about George Soros
what I'm looking for because I want to
make sure I quote it properly but I mean
you know what you wrote but you
basically it reminds me of my videos is
like you know calm down people this is
not like medical people
whoa whoa did you see the Android
laughing is there is there like a new
upgrade that they need Rhonda I think
and Elon needed the upgrade there might
be a software I think it's a state like
it might be something that they need
because something's glitching
it's really weird okay let's and and
what's crazy is the host here is
laughing with him it's kind of weird and
he can't he doesn't do a very good job
this is on a business channel so I'm not
surprised but keep watching here on CNBC
of how great a job he interviews and
just listen to elon's justification of
why he said these anti-semitic tropes
said he wants to erode the very fabric
of civilization and Soros hates Humanity
like when you do something like that
yeah I think that's true that's my
opinion okay but why share it he says
I think that's true it's my opinion your
opinion
is not truth okay here's the truth
George Sowers and his Investment Group
divested from Tesla they dumped all
their [__] Tesla and the reason why
is because Elon is a [__] chucklehead
and he's a [__] and and the Investment
Group was like no we don't want to be
involved in this anymore because he's
going to tank this son of a [__] yeah
and they want and investors send signals
um like we do votes and ballots
investors seek signals with their money
that's how they signal okay that's how
they send signals that's how they send a
message and the Investment Group is
basically telling Tesla hey we're not
gonna We're Not Gonna participate with
you anymore as long as you have this
[__] guy running quote unquote
running your company and he's down and
and I don't know if you've seen the
setting he's in Austin Texas he's in the
Tesla Factory right there in Austin
Texas so he's there he's there as the
Twitter CEO but he's in the setting of
the Tesla CEO yeah well the thing is
like he thinks that they're separate but
he's blurred the lines right I mean and
it's not it didn't just happen but with
Twitter it was every company he's ran
before this especially the ones that are
simultaneous when he had the [__]
Solar City one when he had uh Tesla
SpaceX they're all combined what's the
what's this is it starlink is the one
that link is the other one yeah he
totally he totally has not distinguished
the difference between starlink and
Tesla yeah he had or Twitter because he
uses Twitter to threaten the ukrainians
by taking starlink away they wanted to
take it away but I won't let him and
it's like on his Twitter account where
he owns it's [__] weird man right
it's weird stuff and but listen to what
he says here listen to his entitlement
which is I can't even believe that these
[__] free speech these these people
who talk about freedom and they want all
this dialogue that he's their hero for
this that whatever he believes is truth
that's not truth just listen just
because I believe something just because
Gabe believes something doesn't make it
true it can be true yeah it can be but
it doesn't make it true because we
believe it that's the dumbest [__]
thing I've ever heard everyone can have
you know right Lisa Lisa says this over
here I mean I've I've heard it for
excuses but this is true Elisa says my
dad used to say opinions are like
[__] everyone has one and they
[__] stink normally yeah they find
some people watch some people wash their
[__] and they don't stink all the
time but sometimes the people that are
Fascist or anti-semites or people like
Elon Musk that are [__] right-wing
conspiracy theories like driving people
they have very
stinky ones they're not they're not
founded or grounded in reality they're
based on their own idea of what they
believe is true and then they say well
my opinion is fact because these are
facts and it's like well if your base if
your foundation is built on
misconceptions or misinformation or a
false representation of reality then
your opinions are also going to be
rooted in that right Robin brings up
Lumi you know what's funny about that
Robin is this morning I got another
email from Lumi and it looks like we're
getting closer to having them as an
affiliate sponsor well maybe maybe these
[__] will need a little loomy that's
yeah Escape write it down I know you're
getting an idea write it down I know
you're getting an idea okay so let's
finish up the uh stinky [__] clip
here of this stinky little [__] uh if
we're gonna go back to that word let's
let's watch the rest of Elon here why
sure especially I mean
why share it when people who buy Teslas
may not agree with you advertisers on
Twitter may not agree with you
um why not just say hey I think this you
can tell me we can talk about it over
there you can tell your friends but why
share it why
I mean I I this is freedom of speech I'm
allowed to say what I you absolutely are
but I'm trying to understand why you do
because you have to know it's Gotta
there it puts you in a in the middle of
a this is so stupid why can't you just
say it yes you have the right to say
this [__] but there's consequences to it
you dumbass
that how is this so hard to understand
even the [__] even the host you're
pushing back on him I don't know who the
[__] this idiot is on CNBC but why can't
you just say yes you have the freedom to
say stupid dumb [__] that's not true
that is anti-Semitic it totally looks
like you're being an anti-semite and a
Nazi and supporting white supremacy it
totally looks like that because it is
that and you can do that but there are
[__] consequences to it and the
consequence is that everyone thinks
you're a [__] Nazi why don't you see
that everyone thinks you're a Nazi Elon
you dumb [__] yeah but nobody nobody
will ask him those questions and they'll
know no one will say hey I would
seriously of course Elon come on the
show I I don't think it would be past I
actually think elon's listened to me
talk before because I think Elon Muses
sock accounts to listen to Mario's uh
spaces I think he I think he does and I
think he's heard us talk before I think
he goes in there so Elon and honestly I
I I I I maybe we should try to actually
get and I would bring him on the show I
would eat his [__] lunch it would be
viral video because I would not let him
get away with anything and he would
probably cut the feed because he's a
goddamn pussy-ass [__] and and that
little [__] definitely wouldn't last two
seconds with me on this bike I can
probably uh confidently say after any
appearance that he would have on our
show we would be instantly banned or
[__] Shadow Man from Twitter yeah
let's do it [__] come on Elon that's a
good question are you and are you
anti-semitic you say you're pro-semite
right which I it's
that's Insanity that's insanity
saying saying hearing somebody say I
don't know if you have that in this clip
but hearing him say I'm not anti-semite
I'm actually pro-semite that sounds a
lot like I'm not racist I've got a black
friend right I'm not well it sounds like
I'm not racist I'm the biggest I'm Pro
like dude I'm the least racist person in
this room remember a guy who said that
remember who a guy a guy who said that I
also believe that that guy was pretty
racist
I thought you'd think so huh oh my God
okay let's finish the clip I I can't
remember if that's part of this clip or
not but let's finish it we're we're way
over time here but let's finish this
good the partisan divide in the country
it makes you a lightning rod for
criticism I mean do you like that I you
know people today saying he's an
anti-semite I don't think you are no I'm
definitely I'm like I'm like a pro so
much
so it was just the next step why did you
why do you even have to be like no I'm
not anti-semitic I'm not an anti semi
here's the thing if you're if you're not
anti-semitic stop saying anti-semitic
[__] right stop saying it stop pushing
these conspiracies stop tweeting
anti-semitic [__] man what the reason
why you're pissed off at George Soros is
because he divested from Tesla this
Investment Group and he's Jewish that's
why and if and if you if you don't
understand the absolute
[__] weird thing where you call them
Magneto because you don't understand the
history of Magneto obviously he does
because he why else would he say Magneto
why else if he doesn't know the origin
story why would you bring up an X-Men
character that way why would you say
that what what about George Soros is
comparable or relatable to Magneto
because honestly if he's able to control
metal with his mind like what if if
you're if you're actually if you're
actually wanting to compare it to like
an X-Men character of someone who wants
to destroy civilization you you would
probably go to like Wolverine right now
the Wolverine obviously is used for good
in the X-Men story but Wolverine was the
weapon that was supposed to destroy all
everything right like so you would use
that but he went to Magneto for what
reason
for what reason other than George Soros
is Jewish Magneto in in his origin story
which is I I I'll tell you it's it's
fiction Magneto
I don't know if you know this game
changes X-Men is is fixed yeah it's a
thing are you serious well it's a thing
you're telling me [__] storm a woman
who can't control [__] weather really
Cyclops the guy who has that real laser
vision you're telling me Jean Gray later
Phoenix no not real it's all fictional
mutant that it is it's Fiction it's a
fiction it's Fiction it's fiction and
here's here's the other thing here's the
other thing is that um when when they
cross these roads because I always say
this we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life but this goes
back to the top story where Democrats
are winning in these [__] mayor races
where in in Jacksonville Florida
a Democrat a woman Democrat one over the
Rhonda santus fact Republican
as the mayor race yeah and the reason
why is because of [__] like Elon saying
that just because I say it doesn't mean
there should be consequences and when I
do say it it's real it's it's it's it's
the truth because I am saying it and
because I the institution of white
supremacy is saying it makes it true
like shut the [__] up everyone is sick
and tired of that [__] they're sick and
tired of you saying that you're correct
just because you say it no one buys that
[__] and they're sick and tired of
hearing it and that's why I mean like
just because you purchased a company for
44 billion overpaid by over 30 billion
dollars lost your ass yeah from the
richest man in the world to not yeah
have the idea that you you've you bought
this company and you can say whatever
you say and that makes it true because
that's your opinion I've heard Elon say
a lot of dumb [__] where you know
sometimes he's been checked and a lot of
time he hasn't but you know like even if
you were to go back to when Paul Pelosi
was attacked with a [__] hammer in
his house who was one of the first
people that was like I think this Bears
us to ask more questions right
Elon Musk and what did he do he didn't
apologize when it was actually
discovered that oh the guy wasn't a gay
lover he wasn't a [__] prostitute or
some other conspiracy theory that Elon
well because wait that's because he
believed it Gabe right he believed it so
his opinion but he never happened he
believes it to be true right if he
believes yeah he's like oh well why
would he apologize if he still believes
it but even after the fact somebody
brought it up he's like I did apologize
I'm like no you didn't and now it's like
Elon Musk is like I never said that yeah
yeah but he believed he apologized and
that's his opinion that he believed that
he apologized so that makes it true
again this is that manga cycle this is
the the the white male fragility cycle
where they can't just come to truth or
come to grips with the the actual truth
that hey just because you believe it son
doesn't make it [__] the truth and
that's the [__] story of today and
we're way over time and we're gonna have
to go here sorry about all Gabe's audio
issues I'm not sorry yeah I'm so sorry
wow wow like Michael Virginia Lopez
Hazel that's a long name uh I uh you're
entitled yeah
I want to make sure I got that right uh
like Michael says so perfectly here
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
that is the that's and that's so true
that is so that is a fact but that is
why that is why people are sick of Maga
that is why the won't go broke thing is
not selling around the country with Ron
DeSantis Rhonda Santos is very unpopular
Trump is very unpop there Elon Musk is
very unpopular outside of the fragile
white male incel group yeah and and this
white frag fragility of these white male
incels is not playing around the country
they're sick and tired of the [__]
they're sick and tired of white fragile
men telling everyone else what health
care they're gonna get rather we can be
safe at grocery stores and schools what
[__] books we're going to read who we
can love who we can't who we can marry
they're sick and [__] tired of
fragile white men like Josh Hawley Elon
Musk Donald Trump Ron DeSantis Ted Cruz
Greg Abbott they're sick and tired of
these [__] telling on us what
the hell we're gonna do and telling us
that that facts and Truth aren't truth
because they believe that their opinions
are the truth [__] you and we're gonna
keep coming after him here on the Johnny
Michael's body so don't forget to
subscribe hit the button down below to
subscribe every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific do you have
another comment did you want to oh yeah
I just want to say they were saying it's
two people so they share an account that
makes sense that makes sense that's
right so yeah well Michael in Virginia
thank you very much I don't know which
one
um either one both of you it makes sense
I look at the photo now when I see
Michael in Virginia thank you thank you
thank you thank you for coming thank you
thank you thank you for coming and uh
participating in the show every every
single weekday two full hours or two
hours and ten minutes whichever you want
to count uh rather using magnomics or
not also download every single episode
you know what's funny about your mic
today
when I came into the show I actually I
was actually muted when I came into the
show for reviews I saw that text message
it took me yeah yeah it took me a little
bit you know well so what happens Tony
Tony well I test the mic right and I
usually when I test the mic right before
I go on I leave it unmuted but I must
have muted it so it was just uh it was a
lack of habit there like you tapped at
me that's why yeah because
just keep just just turn it back on
yeah it's back on now no no I mean turn
it like turn the mute on all right now
that it's just us guys get the [__] out
of here get the [__] out of here listen
listen you're gonna want to download uh
this episode today because I'm gonna cut
it to where there is no muting in the
beginning
um I promise I'll cut it and make sure
there's no big space I had to be here if
you were here for the live shows well
they'll they'll they'll hear that I was
muted but they won't hear the mute they
won't get it they'll be like I don't get
the reference why why the hell is he
saying he's muted when we I heard him
from the beginning and by the way if you
want to watch this on Facebook go to
Facebook at the D Tony Michaels at the
Tony Michaels you can watch every single
weekday over there and also thank you
thank you very much for all the support
over on Twitch we got several new
followers today which it's free to
follow we got several new subscribers
today again if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account you can
give us that one free subscription you
get with your Prime account and we get a
couple bucks over on Twitch it doesn't
cost you a single nickel so it's free to
follow and it's also free to link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account and we get a couple bucks it's a
great way to monetize the show so if you
want to show support if you are a prime
user how you do that is you go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com it's about four links down
just click the link that says link
Amazon and twitch it'll give you all the
directions to link those give us your
one free subscription on Amazon gaming
over on Twitch and we get a couple bucks
every single month but you have to do it
every single month so anyone who's done
it and you haven't renewed it go in and
renew it it's almost as quick to renew
it as it is to connect it so go do that
for us that is a great we appreciate all
the support over there
we really do and anyone who gives us
support every single weekday Monday
through Friday two full hours when
you're in the chat when you're sharing
this link whether you're on YouTube
twitch Facebook or Twitter
same time same place tomorrow maybe
audio better tomorrow
it
might be it might be Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon